welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and tomorrow i'm
gonna watch tenet for the first time
so i can bring you the breakdown that
you're watching right now
it's arguably one of christopher nolan's
most complicated movies antenna carries
a lot with its story that is
deliberately made to make the audience
feel confused
throughout the film our protagonist the
protagonist
is introduced to several characters but
he learns very little about them
so there's no way that things can be
compromised ignorance is their best
weapon
and thus the less information that is
provided the more unlikely it is that
sator and the people from the future
will be able to carry out temporal
pinces what this means though is that
there's a ton of different characters in
the film
that all have questions over their heads
but if we look at the little clues we
are given
it is possible to figure out who is who
now the first person i want to talk
about
is the scientists from the future nolan
has a habit of creating doubles in his
films
and this has been shown in movies like
mementos with the multiple lennies and
john g's
in the batman movies there's the two
razzle ghouls bruce wayne and batman
two-face miranda tay and talia algool
and a lot more there's also the twins in
the prestige
as well as the two opposing magicians
and this motif is something that pops up
at multiple points in nolan's movies
now in film terminology this is known as
a hitchcock
double and what the technique typically
involves is placing dopplegangers in
cinematic works
that hint towards their relation and so
on in tenet this of course appears in
the two cats
the two protagonists that fight one
another and potentially
neil and max being one and the same if
you subscribe to that theory
we will be discussing these ideas a lot
through the video
so i feel that they're very important to
bear in mind before we get deeper into
it
now early on in the movie we're
introduced to a scientist named laura
on google casting or barbara if you
check
imdb either way they make it very clear
that this is a woman who has been put in
charge of investigating inverted objects
and the science behind the algorithm
later on in the film we discover from
priya that the scientist who actually
invented the algorithm itself
was a woman generations in the future so
taking these two points it is indeed
possible that the scientist that we meet
early on in the movie
is the person behind the algorithm
itself now firstly we have to take the
term generations
and define how long that actually is
typically a generation is thought to be
between 15 to 30 years
and thus if we take it at its lowest
value it is possible that a 50 to 60
year old laura
discovered how to create the algorithm
and then inverted it to send back to her
past self
the planet at that point could also be
at the point of destabilizing due to
global warming
and therefore things do line up i think
from the way that the film
operates that it becomes clear that the
future protagonists did know the
scientist
and this is how they were able to learn
about inverting the algorithm
and sending it back to the past they
then took this information
and used it to set up the domino pieces
that would eventually lead to their past
self
stopping sator from burying it priya
saying that the scientist
is a she very much plays on the idea of
hitchcockian doubles once more
and leads me to believe that this
specific gender was assigned
because we've already met a scientist
that is studying invasion
and that they are one in the same
however there is another possibility
and this is that it's actually the
scientist's daughter
in the film when she first enters you
can see that laura is actually pregnant
and thus it could be her child that grew
up to study invasion
and that she was the one who did it this
would mean that several generations
could pass
and it gives the film more of a gap
between the present events and the
future
now as for briere she initially starts
off as an arm stealer
that's using her husband as a front for
her company she points the protagonist
in the direction of saito
and we later learn that she is actually
working for tenet
now bria believes herself to be above
all and actually in the inner circle of
the organization
in her eyes she knows the truth about
what's going on and believes that she's
been given the task of tying up the
loose ends
however she herself is a loose end
someone that could potentially leak
information
that could be found by people in the
future and thus
she is a liability though she believes
herself to be a queen
she's actually a pawn used by the
protagonist
who even remarks at an arms dealer being
the easiest trigger that he's had to
pull
therefore he has no issues with using
her as a peace in the chess game
rather than her being someone with
actual power
thus much in the same way that she used
her husband as a front
the future protagonist used her as one
to provide information to himself
she also gave bullets to satos so that
he could invert them
and inevitably this helped him to
collect the pieces of the algorithm
and thus the tenet team could steal them
after they'd been assembled
now though the protagonist could be seen
as someone who's merciless in killing
her
he does give priya an out that would
allow her to survive the events of the
movie
but as she goes back on her word and
attempts to kill kat
she does seal her own fate now there
also exists a theory that was made by
speed sable
which states that priya is actually the
scientist from the future
if this is true then it means that she
created the algorithm and then put in
place this plan which would lead to
sator assembling all of the pieces
so that the protagonist could steal it
dissemble it and then with ives hide the
pieces so that they could never be found
this of course fits in with the plan
that she says the scientist lays out
and her actions get her killed at the
end of the movie
which could be hinting to her taking her
own life which we know that the
scientists did
it also fit in with the aesthetic that
the scientist is a woman
and we also know from priya's husband
that she doesn't mind using men as a
front
with the character the theories are
really just to pick your poison
and of course love to hear which one you
side with below
now as mentioned earlier there exists a
theory that neil and cat's son max are
one in the same
i've already done a big breakdown on
this so don't want to just retread all
ground
but definitely check it out after this
if you have any questions
the main reason i bring it up though is
that nolan purposely had rubber patterns
and dye his hair
and he also made him adopt an accent
that was more in line with cats
so it is safe to assume that this was
done on purpose for a specific reason
now this is also brought across to ives
who adopts a heavy cockney accent in the
film
though this could be seen as his
audition for captain price in a call of
duty movie
and actually could hint at him and sir
michael crosby being one in the same
again this ties into the idea of
hitchcockian doubles
and from what crosby does in the movie
we do get the feeling that he has
knowledge of starsk12
upon meeting him in the restaurant
crosby discusses the secret soviet
cities
and also divulges saito's past which he
knows a lot of details about
sato is quite a private person and thus
crosby knowingness
does hinder him perhaps having studied
him closely
now another thing that he brings up is
that there was an explosion that starts
12
two weeks prior after re-watching the
movie it becomes clear that this
conversation is of course referring to
the climactic battle at the end of the
film
and the explosion that happens at the
hippo center
now it is possible that crosby knew to
have his surveillance keep an eye on the
area
because when he was younger he actually
participated in the mission
ives clearly was recruited by the
feature protagonist which is why he had
no
issues with him joining the splinter
cell at the end of the movie
even though he was a complete stranger
thus it does seem like the two
could know each other and ives may have
taken his piece of the algorithm at the
end
and eventually he went on to ascend
throughout the organization
until he was knighted and became a piece
of the puzzle that would allow the
protagonist to carry out his mission
ives does say that if he ever catches
the protagonist again that he'll kill
him
but because of the way that everything
has to happen the way it has to happen
if he is crosby then he likely realizes
the irony in their conversation
which is where the little british banter
between the two stems from
we love you michael kaine now the final
theory that i'm a bit unsure of
is that the protagonist is actually his
own contact at the cia
we do hear the two talking on the phone
and they do have similar accents
at this point the protagonist is also
thought to be dead
due to taking his cyanide pill so it
doesn't really make sense as to why his
cia contact would not have questions
over this
the opening of the movie also lets us
know that the cia know about the opera
siege in advance
and this is why they are working with
saito's men from neil we learn that the
protagonist has a future in the past
and it is possible that he went back in
time rose through the ranks of the cia
and then recruited himself in order to
assign this mission that would lead to
the events of the film
that's one of the more tenuous theories
but still an interesting one
so i just thought i'd include it i could
say we need to bump up the runtime on
this video
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories on the characters
and if you enjoyed this breakdown then
please drop a thumbs up
don't forget that on the 28th of
february we're giving away three copies
of the phase 3mcu 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
why neil is max which will be linked on
screen right now
we've done a ton of other tenet videos
as well which will be linked in a
playlist
so definitely give them a watch if you
still have more questions over the film
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace